hey guys today i'm going to show
everyone who does not have windows vista
ultimate how to download and install
windows vista's dream scene feature
which allows you to set a video as your
background and i'm going to let everyone
use that what no matter what version of
windows vista you actually have
so go to uh search engine and type in
uh
google preferably which is what i'm
using and type in non
ultimate
dream scene
download
that is what you need to type in
the google search will bring up the
first result being my digital life dot
info
and i'll give you guys this link in the
description
so i'm gonna copy
and i'm gonna paste this into the
description so everyone can get straight
here
scroll down and it'll tell you
scroll that way for it
scroll down and here's the direct link
for the download
click on it and it'll you'll just
extract it to your desktop and you can
install it and everything uh
instructions are also on this website so
if you don't know how to do it the link
in the description will also tell you
exactly how to install all of this
um all these features
so here's what it looks like i'm not
recording full screen right now
but
um
hopefully you can get a good idea of
what it looks like in order to enable
this right click on your desktop
hit the personalize button and this is
where you'll set your desktop background
from here let's just browse to
any
uh video that you have so i go to my
username
videos and this is one of my recently
uploaded youtube videos so i'll hit open
and ok
then hit ok
and i'll exit out so you guys can see
this is actually playing a video in the
background there's my mouse when i
recorded this video
it's playing a video in the background
and i'll just open up my email client on
top it's still
it works just fine
and
the the good part is it doesn't use
quite as much ram as this the ultimate
let's go to
processes and see if we can find it no
that's not it
it actually i can't even find it because
here's the explorer firefox
this is part of vista
this is my thunderbird skype screen
recorder skype speedfan
it's not even it's not even 10 megabytes
of your ram so i'm getting just good
performance here doing a number of tasks
i can have an internet browser open
the notepad calculator whatever i have
to do
and i'm getting just fine performance
with the video uh raging in the
background
so if you guys like what you see uh go
ahead download and install it and if you
decide you don't want it you can
obviously go to personalize
desktop background
and change that back to whatever you had
before
which is what i'll just do there
desktop background
click on
what you had before
and voila it's back to an image
so
uh if you like what you saw
go ahead and download it and install it
the instructions are in the description
and if you like it subscribe guys more
videos to come peace